hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the video World Cup noted the
battle for first place but the battle
for third place it is Fabiana corvana
versus ninja tabasova ending this match
both players actually came to play some
chess so uh let's not spoil anything
let's dive straight into it quite a lot
to enjoy uh of course you know from the
previous game where ninja won a
brilliancy with the white pieces Fabi
now needs to strike back in order to
force tie breaks so it's either gonna be
a ninja who wins third place and there
are no games tomorrow or Fab equalizes
today and then we get more chess
tomorrow so let's see what happened here
Bobby has the white pieces and he opens
with Pawn to E4 we have Pawn to C5 uh
Ninja goes for the Sicilian Defense we
have Knight to F3 E6 and now Pawn to D4
we have characters captures and now
Knight to C6 with Knight to C3 and
Knight to F6 and more often than not you
will see 90 the B5 here and we've seen
this um a technique quite a lot in the
World Chess Championship match between
none other than Fabiano Cortana and the
Magnus Carlson but here Fabi opts for
Bishop to F4 and it's actually the ninth
most popular move in this position and
here he says uh okay obviously you are
very strong I know you're prepared but
how how prepared are you really and here
uh it has been it really hasn't been
played quite a lot especially in top
tier chess there is one game from 2021
from Sunway sieges tournament where
abhimanyu purani defeated uh Arjun Erica
AC with this move but in that game D6
was played here we have Bishop to B4 uh
and now Knight to B5 only now going for
an ID to B5 not threatening Knight to C7
check and Fabi says what do you play
here are you are you prepared for this
do you know your stuff and ninja says
yes I do Knight captures an E4 and this
is indeed the the top move
just to give you an example of course
you guys are wondering is Knight the C7
checker thing here and not really even
with perfect play uh White gets uh just
a dead draw here and if white even makes
the slightest of mistakes then white can
get a very bad position just to give you
a quick example let's say queen F6 and
now black pass up on the pawn here and
the Knight here also the bishop on F4
now we're gonna play Queen F3 and not
Knight captures on C3 of course you go
back with the bishop now comes Knight to
D4 and now the Knight wants to capture
on C2 so you have to prevent this now
you get Queen to E5 with check Bishop D2
and now Knight captures and C2 with
check just a brutal brutal uh variation
of course Queen cannot capture due to
Checkmate I need to so King has the move
now you play Knight to E4 again uh
putting pressure on the on the bishop
here so Bishop capture some B4 has to be
played Knight captures attacks the queen
queen to A3 not pinning the knights to
the king and queen to C5 and black has a
very very good position threat trackmate
and the only move for white would be to
trade Queens Queen E3 black happily
trades and not after Knight to C2 uh
black will get one more pawn and then
with three extra Pawns of course you're
not interested that you're done the
exchange black will be much much better
here let's say Rook C1 that captures an
E3 with check and after King to G1 just
King E7 you defend the bishop here uh
black is uh well pretty much winning
here so that's why you don't go for
Knight to C7 check right away Bobby
plays Queen to F3 and now Pawn to D5
with Knight to C7 with check King to f8
and now Queen side Castles by Fabi so
this is uh or this is all been played
before and both of them are playing the
absolute top engine moves uh Bishop
captures and C3 now destroying five is
Queen side and B captures on C3 and here
uh the top moves are E5 and G5 and both
of them have been played in this
position even the move that is being
played in this position uh Queen to E7
that in Egypt plays which is a mistake
uh has also been played before which is
funny because you are going after the A3
Square you want to deliver this check
and with the Knight covering D2 which
should be very nice for you however Fabi
plays Pawn to C4 and he played it pretty
much instantly so he shows that he knows
his stuff The Queen Is Now controlling
the A3 square and there's really no good
move here for black you just have to
accept that Queen to E7 was a waste of a
Tempo because if you try to save your
Rook now with Rook the B8 then look at
the C captures on D5 already you're
losing material if you try to recapture
Knight captures attacks your queen and
after Queen moves and now Bishop
captures on V8 Knight captures on V8 and
queen to A3 with check King will move
and now Knight to the E7 with check King
goes here you can even go for some
windmill action another check King has
to move 97 check King goes here and I'll
Bishop the B5 check a bishop to B5
attacks the queen
and that's pretty much it it usually if
we had a if we had a name for uh an
attack on the queen like yeah that'd be
useful uh but yeah
Knight to C6 will you know lose uh for
black in um a few more moves if you
capture right away then you just go for
Instant Checkmate and that's it so uh
you cannot uh play Rook to B8 even
though it's okay it's a valid question
can this be played but here we have
Queen to F6 uh and it is now as of move
12 that we have a completely new game so
how can Fabi deal with this queen to F6
move well he goes of course another
thread is a queen A1 Checkmate the
Knight is covering the D2 Square so Pawn
to C3 and now we have Pawn to G5
attacking the bishop Bishop to D6 check
we have King to G7 and now Fabio goes
first queen captures on F6 King captors
and now Knight captures an A8 okay you
you win the exchange at night captures
and D6 and the C captures on D5 we have
e characters and Fabi doesn't go for the
pawn on D5 he plays Pawn to F3 uh he
doesn't want to see best from G4 with an
attack on the rook and then the Rook can
grab the Knight on A8 so here we have
Knight to F5 going after the E3 square
and now Knight to C7 so you don't have
to worry about any discoveries from The
Rook uh Pawn to D4 uh we have Bishop to
B5 by Fabi and now Knight to E3 he
attacks The Rook here and the G2 Pawn so
Rook to D2 and now Bishop to D7
uh we have Rook D1 and now Rook the C8
putting pressure on the Knight here uh
the threat was uh with Rook D1 of course
uh Fabi just wants to capture on E3 and
after captures captured the bishop on D7
Sony just says all right you capture on
E3 I'm gonna take the Knight on C7 and
okay perfectly fine real captures real
captures and now Rook to E4 going after
the pawn here yeah or rather just
defending the pawn and getting out of
the way uh and here the absolute best
way to play this is the Play Bishop to
F5 now you have to go into Bishop
captures on C6 so The Rook is defended
uh and now after Rook captures on C6 you
will play Rook captures on e4 and okay
you can capture and C3 King to B2 now
comes Rook to C5
and you continue the playing this year
you're down a pond with white uh rather
you're down sorry you're down opponwood
white but you are up the exchange uh so
white will be a little bit better here
nothing uh nothing too much however the
captures on C3 was played Here and Now
Fabi gets the initiative he goes for
Rook to D6 with check King to G7 and now
Rook to E3 uh the top uh engine move is
actually Rook to D5 but it's a really
weird inhuman way to play this you go
after the G5 pawn and after H6 now you
go Rook to C5 and really there are no uh
you know even good moves for black here
if A6 just Bishop A4 and if the shot and
if I want to B5 we're gonna play Bishop
to B3 and now you still cannot unpin
here you have to play some like Rook D7
to move the Rook now you just capture on
C3 and the game continues you get rid of
the nuisance that is the Pawn on C3 and
retain a better position okay yeah Rook
D3 was played instead and now we have
Pawn to A6 Bishop to A4 and the bishop
up to E6 now going after the A2 pawn and
we have a trade of pretty much
everything Bishop captures on C6 B
captures and C6 root captures on C3
Bishop captures and A2 and now Rook C
captures
uh Rook C captures and C6 going after
the rook and the pawn on A6 so Rook to
E7 and now Rook captures an A6 so all of
the pawns on the queen side get
eliminated and now we are left with this
position where it's uh three pawns each
on the king side two Rooks against the
rook and Bishop so can this be one uh
it's very hard to say with perfect play
probably with perfect play against
perfect play probably not so you know
it's uh it all depends uh whether you're
able to find that Fortress or not uh
some positions are very much winning
some are not uh basically it's uh how
how well you defend so okay we have Rook
to E2 going after the pawn and only one
move stops that so that's Rook to D2
with Rook D1 checking the B2 and not
Bishop to E6 and yeah
um uh for for Ninja tapasov uh creating
a fortress here means the difference
between uh you know going into tie
bricks and winning the match directly in
classical time format as he already won
the first game so he really wants to
hold this to a draw and Fabi will of
course try to play this for forever if
he if he needs to so Rook day one kicks
away the roof from the uh from the
active first rank will Rook D5 now comes
King to C3 and okay Pawn to H6 we have
King to D4 Rook to B5 and now King the
E3 with rooked the B3 check King F2 and
now Rook the B4 Albertson says alright
I'm waiting for you show me show me what
you got uh we have rooked A5 Fabi now
needs to figure out a plan on how to
even create some chances because uh
without creating uh some sort of a
weakness there is no way of uh
eliminating anything here the pawn card
the the defense the bishop dh51 defends
the G5 one there just aren't any
weaknesses here so Rook to H4 goes after
the H2 Pawn Fabi plays H3 Rook back the
B4 and now King to G3 and just King F6
ninja says all right show me show me
what you got uh Rook to E2 and now
Bishop to F5 and now Shifting the bishop
over to G6 we have Rook e to E5
attacking the bishop and just Bishop the
G E6 we have Rook e to B5 trying to
trade off uh Rooks uh but just Rook C4
we have Rook the B6 check King to G7 and
now uh Rook 8 to B5 we have rooked the
C2 now uh and here Fabi needs to figure
out a way on how to how to play H4 and
F4 he wants to play H4
uh and then Force G captures on H4 and
then get this Pawn all the way to F5
that's pretty much the only thing that
Fabi can do so Rook to B2 uh we have
rooked the C4 and now Rook 2 to B4 it'd
be very useful if the Rook wasn't on C2
so when Fabi pushes this that he can
capture and The Rook will not be
attacking the G2 Pawn uh but okay we
have rooked the C5 Here and Now Rook 6
to B5 again offering a trade and just
Rook back the C2 he says nope I'm very
comfortable here uh we have rooked to D5
and now Rook to A2 we have Pawn to H4 uh
and now G captures an H4 and uh look at
this King captures an H4 now what's the
idea here this is the uh sorry uh not
King captures Rook captures on H4 and of
course the King has to keep an eye on
this Pawn Here and Now Pawn to H5 and
now what was fabi's idea here of course
the one that we've already mentioned he
wants to play F4 and F5 now the other
thing
um you're probably wondering is is it
possible to not capture here why would
you willingly ruin your Pawn structure
well the problem is your g51 is attacked
twice so you can't just do nothing here
and F6 creates too much
um of a draft here your king will not be
defended you need to have the pawn on a
light Square so the bishop and pawn
creates a sort of a barrier uh you know
from the white Rooks so you have to
capture this with Rook characters and
now of course spawn to H5 and Rook uh
back to B4 uh we have rooked the C2 and
now Pawn to F4 now Fabi wants to play
Pawn to F5 and this is uh where it all
basically begins now well King to H6 uh
I've uh actually left the engine to
Crunch the numbers here uh and after
some depth 50 the engine says that yeah
white is much much better but the engine
still cannot win this so uh King H6 is
the mood that the engine plays um a very
very hard to uh to actually prove
something here uh King the F6 is what
Ninja had played and now comes Rook to
G5 and now the question is what do you
play here to actually hold this with
black that's the question feel free to
pause the video and what would you play
this so imagine you are defending this
position with black why would you play
this why would you play in this position
what is White's plan what is Fabi
threatening with Rook to G5 uh would you
lose this game or would you hold against
Fabi and uh you know clinch third place
in defeated World Cup 2023 figure it out
while I give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it uh congratulations uh on uh you
know uh always studying the end game and
being a spectacular endgame player and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is Rook the C1 for those of
you who are wondering why I was just
laughing I was just reading some
comments on my previous video and
someone wrote how many times uh has
Magnus had food poisoning yeah seems
like he he always gets food poisoning
really you know what does he eat uh but
yeah our Rook to see one is the more you
should play and it's not the move that
was played the point behind this is that
let's say after Rook the V6 check and
King G7 you you play F5 it doesn't work
uh because King H6 attacks the rook and
after F characters on G6 King captures
and G5 and F captures and G7 you can
easily stop the pawn Rook to F1 and on
the other hand if you don't push F5
right away if you prepare it with King
to H4 now F5 would be deadly uh then
Rook the H1 comes in very handy that's
why a rook needs to be on the back crank
you go back and then roll back to C1
this is how you hold however after Rook
to G5 Rook the C6 was played and
stopping Rook to B6 but now uh I I
actually thought about making this the
pause the video moment but I thought it
was much much harder for you to actually
stop uh what was coming now than to
actually realize what the play here uh
and now of course Fabi plays King to H4
and now you don't have Rook to H1 check
so there is nothing you can do here
pretty much Bishop to F5 of course wrote
characters on H5 so you can play that
Rook D6 was played and now of course
spawn to F5 at Bishop captures on F5
with the move you were wondering about
of course doesn't not winning the game
you have to play Rook to F4 now go after
the bishop here Rook the E5 and now just
Rook captures on H5 and he was in this
position on move 59 that in Egypt abasov
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so fab equalizes
and we will have more just tomorrow as
Fabi forces tie breaks and now uh the
the match for third place is still being
uh being fought now the reason you
resign here is fairly simple I want to
unpin King E6 you can just play Pawn to
G4 and now after the bishop moves you
just straight here captures captures and
it seems like you still have your
Fortress it's uh the problem is the king
is outside of the Fortress if the King
was inside of the Fortress okay we're
talking about something here but after
King G5 there is nothing here King to B6
you're gonna play Rook to F6 with
checking E7 and you just destroy the
entire Fortress Rook captures on G6 Pawn
captures King captures and after King f8
King to H7 and now once you control
these three squares you can just Advance
your Pawn to victory that that's it King
F7 we're gonna push the pawn here
doesn't really matter what you're
playing king of Fate you're gonna push
the pawn you're gonna play King here
push the Pawn King here push the pawn
with check and now of course you
Checkmate um the black king in some
seven moves uh so I have to look after
some H5 uh Fabi wins and the what a
victory what a victory it was and it's
good for Fabi to bounce back like this
psychologically I mean a player of uh
his um his uh you know uh skill set uh
of course you don't become a former 2800
by not being able to bounce back after a
single loss so even though it was a
devastating loss and he just played a
brilliant game haven't seen it do check
it out I will even put a link to it in
the description below first link you
will see an Egypt absolutely demolished
Fabiano so do check it out if you if you
haven't seen it but yeah probably just
bounces back like I said maybe you can
hold that
um like I don't know you you you would
probably hold it against your friend but
not against that you know a friend who
who plays the best chess uh out of all
of your friends and then you know uh you
would not be able to hold it against the
Grand Master but then again Grandmaster
would not be able to win it against an
engine so it's it's hard to say uh so
yeah that's the game I really hope you
guys enjoyed it I would like to thank um
uh girl Ninja's festival.org.gg film
Autos carticola David Kimura and Franz
pan card for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here and thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the fide
World Cup until it finishes uh so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day